bene tutti ragazzi venuti a questo video
sono vigenti oggi proviamo tre giochi da
un sito che propone giochi diversamente
intelligenti partiamo col primo so che
non mettete mi piace quando non ho
neanche visto il gioco solo l'apertura
con il calzino e la voce robotizzata
merita il mi piace quality content
signori sia un su skinn lochhead che dal
nome sembrano roba incredibile e penso
che lo sia
l'ho pagato 3 dollari e 66 centesimi
vediamo se ne vale la pena
il tasto sinistro per andare avanti coi
pedali e fin qua tasso adesso per
bloccare ok a posso andare anche
all'indietro scrollo zuma la mappa
start the first rays che sono partito
veramente da dio allora e non ho ben
capito il suo gioco di che cosa
in che cosa consista però devo devo
schivare le macchine quindi si parla
sempre di family friendly l'importante
quello hai visto youtube che sto
cambiando per andare in contro
l'algoritmi hai visto che porto giochi
che non hanno sangue sono family
friendly tantissimo non vedo cosa ci sia
di sbagliato in questo giorno è un tutto
è vabbè però mica mischiati ogni tre
secondi un duro questo mi stanco
impegnandola fermi un attimo che devo
andare alla alla so parlare non so e
allora io e dovete capire che non sono
multitasking
io non riesco a fare due azioni
contemporaneamente quindi o parlo ho
guido non posso fare due cose insieme
quindi quando avrò la patente se mai ce
l'ha però non parlerò mai al telefono
perché devo capire che cosa consiste
quindi andiamo prima al consiglio a
quanto so cosa mangiavano scusami eh
vabbè ce lo vedo in teoria dovrebbe
essere qua tra l'altro è una città più
dettagliata di quella di spider man per
playstation 4 non vedo perché la gente
debba comprare spider man
perché spendere 60 euro per spider me
quando con tre dollari e 66 che ora sono
circa 33 euro quindi ancora meno che
dovessi comprare spider risparmi soldi
ci hai un gioco del genere c'è una scusa
miste de pazzi e compra spider man
bennie steps 5 qualcosa no aspè che c'è
il gradino a ok
cosa può fare a devo raggiungere i cosi
in tempo un minuto per aggiungerli tutti
bene
già se devo ricominciare a non mi fai
ricominciare vi farei sposare di fianco
però devi stare calmo se vai in macchina
perché sono tv tra ritirare la patente
cioè non è che posso essere investito ho
capito che sono all'incontro vano però
vi siete un po collaborativi soprattutto
to transenne questo comunque del libero
simulator cosa visto che sto portando lì
di roba sulla schiena spiega cos'è
quella roba lì e il panino di qualcuno
che aveva ordinato davis per scoprire
new record pensate che ricordo c'era
prima
quindi questo l'ho fatto e mi ha
sbloccato altre cose da fare molto bene
salve signora vedo che ha un paraurti
molto ben curato complimenti devo
riuscire a fermarmi qua perfetto city
loop la madonna continuerà a messi tre
minuti e 48 aveva non è che sono
superman rega centro aiuti a 48 non li
faccio ma cosa se gioca spider man ma
stai scherzando togliete vi devo fare il
record
devo consegnare i panini col demonio
quanto in casi natuzzi non ci passano
mai
invece ci sono passato quasi del tutto
grazie è molto gentile
vedo che la gente si ferma
veramente un birillo in grado di fare
questo ragazzi birilli sono persone
orribili non credete birilli fatte
passare chi se ne frega del traffico
devo fare le cose giuste via quanto
tempo quanto traffico
io non ho mai visto un gioco con
dettagli però lei è un po se lo lasci
dire non ho mai visto un gioco così
dettagliato in tutta la mia vita regata
lavorativi idranti sono dei pokémon cosa
serve il training questo gioco tocchi
una mosca e sei morto come possibile
asti ciclistica arrivato più della
macchina c'è cosa vai a fare in macchina
forse perché i tuoi amici schiatti
effettivamente potrebbe esserci una
motivazione valida ci metterò una via
non ce la farò mai a fare sta roba in
due minuti lo sapete
impossibile come faccio a prendere tra
l'altro ho notato che in strada vai
velocissimo molto più veloce che su un
marciapiede devo capire il perché
l'asfalto ti dà più ti fa sfrecciare di
più se sta roba makeba schiantarmi non
c'era bisogno
devi darmi la bce bastava che mi desta
dalla macchina qualsiasi vedete che non
sapeva guidare uguale forse ci riesco se
rimango in strada però diventa veramente
difficile schivare le macchine ogni
tanto che ai no no no con un minuto di
scarto cioè incredibile sono bravissimo
però devi devi mettere le frecce quando
giri next
ecco cosa devo fare in un minuto 41
spiega mi fai tutto questo è ciò che non
devi fare nient'altro che prendere i
cosi sono tre euro ben spesi
cosa si può fare con 3 euro che non ho
fatto dare alla sala giochi tirarli
addosso a pietro per qualsiasi altra
cosa di utile tranne comprare questa sì
non so ancora con quale fisica ma è
appurato che se stai in strada se i
dieci volte più veloce va bene ritmica
sono anche diventato sarà vietato
bravino pensate
miss hanno sfilato in un gioco
completamente inutile invece le fai
sordi support nei non ho capito niente
nella vita io dovevo fare quello sì però
e mi sono un po triturato i maroni posso
fare qualcos'altro
perché si ingrossano se due auto vabbè
dai ho visto già troppo va bene così sto
gioco è carino bastato baby come vedete
non vi sto mentendo questo per le spese
di spedizione che sono 66 centesimi l'ho
pagato proviamo altre cose tipo vc gate
decidete un gioco dove le coppie si
divertono e si tirano la sabbia devo
cambiare spacciatori di videogiochi mi
sa clic su start e qualcuno che mi no
anzi non voglio spiegazioni
allora questa è una mano si vede che
questo gioco è gratis
si vede un sacco allora e io credo anche
di essere incinta ma meno male che non
devo fare così perché si tocca la pancia
in modo strano sono incinta io sono la
tizia guarda more war guardami guardami
sono incinta
guardami sono incinta guardami
tu non sei il padre perché so devo fare
e posso muovermi anno devo tirare la
sabbia addosso a mio marito anche
prenderlo sberle perché realistico
studio tutti sono concentrati sulla mia
mano devo ancora capirne il motivo
tesoro mi passi del le patatine
eccole qua lo trovate tieni mangia
mangia che io non posso sono incinta non
posso ma no non è vero che in città
mangio un sacco
vi è mai capitato di fare una figura di
cacca dicendo una ragazza incinta
pensando sul serio e lontane era
semplicemente un po grassa
ecco a me no però ho visto un sacco di
film dove succede o il costante terrore
che possa succedere mi davvero no no non
puoi bere se non puoi bere fiber e lui
non credo che questo sia il modo giusto
di bere però ok
vedo che c'è del dettaglio in questo
gioco telefono cioè un telefono che ha
solo spotify e volevo chiamare mia mamma
e dalla novella notizia la lieta notizia
non sono riuscito parco lemonia magnate
padani non ho capito il senso di un
telefono che cambia solo musica l'amore
mi hai visto
siamo veramente disagiati il nostro
figlio e condannato a morte vigliatore
io conosco la versione italiana di
questi a briatore jam jam ha tutta
l'aria di essere una specie di super
meat boy un po più un caramelloso
proviamo ma che gioco carino fatto bene
salve io sono un omino e sei morto vabbè
la storia triste e terribile
cosa è successo il castello è stato
conquistato dal malvagio orsetto gommoso
il principe è stato preso prigioniero
abbiamo bisogno di aiuto ma vi aiuto io
amici miei che sono un eroe per sono io
sì è vero ti posso permettere solo che è
assolutamente come super meat boy a puoi
anche dettare i nemici così
figo perché avesse gratis invece quella
cagata in bici l'ho pagata a 3 euro però
dei problemi non solo salire uso lui
come scala agli ami fai male
vai vai su sono morto
non sono buoni si vede che è fare
discariche cose gratis e alcune cose
finché ci sono burlati ok ma devo far
fuori tutti i nemici per forza ok dai un
livello lo voglio fare almeno a rischio
sono tutti diversi
porca vacca che male sono carini sti
cosi l'unico problema è che non capisco
cosa sono io c'è capisco cosa sono gli
altri tipo pipistrelli orsetti gommosi
ma non ho capito chi sono io che male
quanto vorrei che casa mia fosse
assalita dalla roba gommosa ragazzino
tantissimo dove tra l'altro quando mori
morì definitivamente ce lo devi iniziare
per forza la capo cioè adesso mi rimasto
un cuore che succede
sono morto ma chi muoverti fare i falchi
all'inizio ogni volta va beh sembra
carino e sono un po strana ai primo
l'ultima volta se ne scappano roba
recente perfetto una prima botta l'ho
già presa la seconda pure dopo aver
giocato super meat boy puoi giocare
qualsiasi cosa li sto genere che se
riesci in tutto tranne in questo che va
un pò un casino più difficile ammazzare
questi bijoux bat nelle caverne di
pokémon sono i ragni ragazzi sono i
ragni e la cosa che adoro di più nella
mia vita e ragni grazie mille contento
che li avete messi porca vacca sparano
pure perché ci sta un cuore li molto
bene è un ragno non muore immortaleranno
immortale ve l'ho detto io che si così
sono le bestie di satana io ve l'ho
sempre detto dovete morire
ok no
[Musica]
vabbè però è stato carino ma i ragazzi
prodotto tre giochi un po diversi quello
che mi ha dato più soddisfazione
senz'altro è quello dove ho tirato della
sabbia addosso a mio marito che ha
appena scoperto che sono incinta e poi
la gente si preoccupa di seguirla
trovano i videogiochi ragazzi spero che
questo video sia piaciuto spero che la
qualità video ludica che sto portando
sul mio canale incrementi sempre di più
e vi ringrazio per questo per tutto il
sostegno come al solito ragazzi se vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento è un mi
piace anche a vari social che comiziare
se non si lavora ci si schieri e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo vi da ragazzi
[Musica]